[Music]
in radio pirate news submitted by a
secret admirer a local radio station
keeps getting hijacked by a song about
masturbation wow there's a jackoff so
what is it about the sneaky DJ in there
my dick jockey that comes from all right
so what's the song are we gonna hear yes
you guys will hear a little clip of the
song at the chorus and so this song is
called the winkers song the Winker 70's
song by an artist named Ivor Biggins
hi poor big uns yeah any better in bed
up your own Biggums brother mm-hm and so
they this way dear radio station named
Mansfield 103.2 from the UK they've been
hacked at least eight times within the
last month and so they playing this song
that uses the word wanker 36 times in
1970 the Beatles wankers
control is the best and that's how that
must mean you never like switches you're
gonna be like what they didn't have
internet back then because when you have
Internet's you use the right hand to
navigate with your mouse so you start to
learn how to jack off with your left
magazine you flip that we should still
hold the magazine with one hand on your
left hand Joe love for Lawson you got to
learn a DJ method don't worry like you
better grab a Chris the managing
director of this radio station who's
receiving a lot of complaints from
families saying that kid
started humming this song I'm a wanker
it's catching out if you're humming here
what's the harm bad words either UK
Waker is a bad word that's not for us
like you hear like member Gordon Ramsay
Hank are you [ __ ] like a pretty bad
word something like bloody is there
[ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] you so bloody and
wanker you bloody wanker that's worse
than like you mother [ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean I think it's equivalent a wanker
the fuel of a wet you're gonna get
bleeped out if this goes to the UK that
means you're a [ __ ] bleeding jacker
offer yeah you jack off so hard you got
no [ __ ] skin look oh bloody wanker
getting from your hand rips the bank you
brought a way you'd also mentioned that
there were people calling saying that
they found it hilarious
of course adults are gonna find it
hilarious but if your kids walking
around saying [ __ ] keep up [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I've been like know what
the help so who is the man behind the
Hat they're still looking for on they're
looking for this radio pirate oh they're
naming him you can't name him there's a
radio station in the East Coast that
uses my chuck-e-cheese from a birthday
song as a morning show opening what yeah
in the East Coast
I think it's New Jersey or something
like that no royalty no royalties they
send people I still make money on that
song because people come and search for
it so I'm like whatever yeah yo can you
give them a sample of it I don't know
check G for my birthday
Chuckie Chuckie Chuckie Cheese from the
birthday
check your chicken chicken cheese from a
birthday suckit suckit suckit cheese
from a birthday birthday I said that
goes off for me wait what do they use it
for further it's like an opening for
their radio talk show like a morning
show but you have to watch the video
that's attached to it that's fine I just
want to make a song would you say [ __ ]
a lot a bit a bit better 36 Hal allowed
though okay oh you mean Oh problem and a
samurai sword early costume no I'm
unlucky he's not it oh you used to have
crazy customs right there in the dry
cleaners they were saying that this
pirate was able to overcome the Airways
because of a small transmitter that they
had so one person is saying they're
hacking us through the small transmitter
but then there's another person saying
there's no way they need a huge
transmitter because it takes a lot more
than something really small to take over
the Airways so we don't even know
exactly how they're taking over but they
are and they still lovely happening
internally I have a feeling - I don't
think it'd be that easy to hack a radio
station it could be a small evasion oh
my god it's just the song is so
kid-friendly though did Bill Gates
already make the note the the the the
Moorefield condom that he was talking
about what what is it game Connie was
talking about making a condom that's
gonna feel like you just literally have
nothing there at all that was Bill Gates
Bill Gates
Dave had a warning mo-fuckers who think
about making more you just spray it on
your dick hahahaha and then it just
wraps around it and it just feels
amazing because cardio is not the devil
yeah
I don't [ __ ] know probably coming on
but we did an article about it oh yeah
we did I don't know about that man that
lack sounds nasty but safety with
pleasure might be almost a spot and then
it just so happens to be the whole word
and you're gonna have a kid you see four
girls if they see like bad guys spread
on the ice like spider-man how long does
it take to realize like spider-man I
don't know but he was talking about
though and I was like super excited I
was like yo man this guy's a good good
man wait for the condom so weird
just like with you I can't picture you
wait around in my hand and just make a
really big balloon and go like a brother
like I don't want to never have sex yeah
tell me that you only [ __ ] monkeys
that's right Laura gets [ __ ] by
monkeys Oh that'd be awesome getting
[ __ ] monkey but I can't fix it's not
for me sometimes to what I saw
chimpanzees at the zoo and you know they
don't got but what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links in the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]